guten abend aus moskau am sonntag kommt
der russische präsident wladimir putin
nach deutschland am montag belegt
gemeinsam mit kanzlerin merkel die
hannover messe eröffnen die größte
industriemesse der welt die
handelsbeziehungen sind eng wir leben
von russischem öl und gas und russland
kauft unsere autos und maschinen
aber der präsident kommt zu einem
zeitpunkt nach deutschland zudem die
irritation über die politische
entwicklung dort bei uns groß ist
deshalb freue ich mich dass er sich
heute abend unseren fragen stellt
präsident wladimir putin guten abend
scheint mit einem peer präsident
deutschland und russland das ist eine
besondere beziehung wirtschaftlich passt
das prima zusammen politisch hakt es
zurzeit ein bisschen viele deutsche
sehen mit sorge
razzien bei hunderten von
nichtregierungsorganisationen in
russland zwei deutsche politische
stiftungen sind betroffen
die deutsche öffentlichkeit hat die
erklärung da soll eingeschüchtert werden
warum handeln ihre behörde so ich glaube
sie schüchtern die deutsche
öffentlichkeit ein
es passiert doch gar nichts ähnliches
muss die menschen nicht einschüchtern
man muss objektiv die entwicklungen
beleuchten und was ist denn die
objektive beleuchtung
ende vergangenen jahres wurde in
russland ein gesetz verabschiedet nach
dessen maßgabe der russischen föderation
diejenigen nichtregierungsorganisationen
die finanzielle unterstützung aus dem
ausland erhalten aus dem ausland
finanziert werden und die eine
politische tätigkeit hierzulande
betreiben sich registrieren lassen
müssen als ausländische agenten
also es geht es hier um organisationen
die innerhalb unseres landes auf
politischem parkett agieren und sich um
ausländische geld
fallen lassen das ist kein besonderes
novum in der globalen politischen 0 1
genau solches gesetz in den usa seit
acht 1938 sie zusätzliche fragen habe
ich mich sehr gerne diesen fragen
stellen um ihnen zu erklären was
passiert und ihren also unseren
zuschauern
herr präsident mir ist nicht bekannt
dass in den usa ähnliche durchsuchungen
beschlagnahmen stattfinden
der begriff ausländischer agent den die
organisationen tragen müssen
in unseren ohren hört sich das nach
kalten krieg an
dann werde ich präzisieren
in den usa gibt es ein solches gesetz es
ist dann rafft bislang in kraft und
unsere russischen organisatoren werden
mit der gleichen frage konfrontiert die
in dort vor jahrzehnten eingeführt
worden ist
ich werde ihnen gleich ein papier
überreichen
das amerikanische justizministerium die
nichtregierungsorganisationen sucht
dokumente bereit zu stellen die dann
dass sie die gelder aus dem ausland
erhalten und dort gibt es eine lange
liste von fragen werden haben ein genau
ähnliches gesetz verabschiedet das
nichts verbietet das möchte ich
unterstreichen dieses gesetz verbietet
ja nichts dieses gesetz schränkt nichts
ein und lässt niemanden dicht machen und
keine tätigkeit selbst in der politische
tätigkeit viel für organisationen die
sich aus dem ausland finanzieren ist
nicht verboten
wir wollen nur wissen wer dieses geld
bekommt und wofür dieses geld ausgegeben
wird
ich wiederhole dass es keinen
um das wir uns haben einfallen lassen
aber warum ist das so
aktuell für uns was glauben sie wie viel
gibt es in europa nicht regierungs
organisationen die sich aus russland
finanzieren lassen
was glauben sie persönlich kann das
einschätzen herr präsident ich kann ja
auch nur über meinen ich werde es ihren
sagen eine solche organisation gibt es
in paris und die andere die zweite
organisation des nordamerika tätig und
ist in den usa eine firmen registriert
worden es gibt zwei insgesamt einmal in
den usa einmal in europa habe schon
geahnt dass sie mich fragen werden wie
heißen sie übrigens schauen sie doch mal
in der russischen föderation schiff so
gibt es sich bei 6 254
nichtregierungsorganisationen die wer
sich herausgestellt hat geld hin aus dem
ausland beziehen 644 organisationen das
ist ein ganzes netzwerk das die ganze
russische föderation erfasst alle
regionen der russischen föderation nur
in den vier monaten nachdem wir das
entsprechende gesetz verabschiedet haben
haben diese organisationen aus dem
ausland stellen sie sich nur vor
sie können sich kaum vorstellen und ich
wusste es auch recht also haben diese
organisationen 28 milliarden 300
millionen rubel das ist knapp eine
milliarde us dollar bis 1 40 855
millionen bekamen sie über diplomatische
vertreter das sind die organisationen
die eine politische tätigkeit
hierzulande betreiben darf denn unsere
gesellschaft nicht wissen wer und wo für
sein geld bekommt und ich möchte
unterstreichen ich möchte dass sie es
wissen und dass die europäer es wissen
dass die deutschen alles wissen
niemand verbietet mit dieser
organisation
wir bitten nur dass sie zugeben ja wir
betreiben die politische tätigkeit aber
lassen uns aus dem ausland finanzieren
die gesellschaft hat einen anspruch
darauf und man muss niemanden
einschüchtern dass hier jemand
festgehalten wird dass hier etwas
beschlagnahmt wird vielleicht hätte man
das beschlagnahmen können wenn die
menschen im gesetz verletzen dort gibt
es administrative strafen aber ich
glaube dass alles vollzieht sich im
rahmen von zivilisierten regeln
nach unserem verständnis funktioniert
demokratie mit einer starken opposition
nach unserem verständnis es eine
opposition immer regierung im wartestand
gibt es auch in der politik wettbewerbs
ist im zweifel besser machen kann als
eine regierung braucht russland eine
starke opposition
natürlich braucht ich werde gleich die
frage beantworten hier sind die
dokumente die unsere organisationen in
den usa bereit zu stellen haben uns
gucken sie von wem dieser liste
unterschrieben ist das ist der
aufklärungs dienst das ist keine
generalstaatsanwaltschaft das ist sehr
aufklärung dienst des justizministeriums
tiroler das ist das dokument dass man an
die organisation und verschickte und
gucken sie wie viele fragen sie zu
beantworten haben ist das demokratisch
oder nicht herr präsident wir schauen
uns der solche menschen hier ist von
ähnlichen durchsuchungen usa wie gesagt
nichts bekannt ich will auf die nächste
frage kommen
ich halt gerade schon gesagt nach
unserem verständnis lebt demokratie auch
von einer starken opposition eine
opposition die sind zweifel immer besser
machen kann als die regierung wettbewerb
um das politische geschäft braucht
russland nicht auch eine starke position
natürlich braucht russland eine starke
opposition und nicht nur das ich glaube
ohne
wettbewerb ist keine entwicklung möglich
einen politischen bereich und im
wirtschaftlichen bereich
wir wollen diese entwicklung
gewährleisten für unser land und für
unseren menschen ohne diesen wettbewerb
ist es unmöglich effektiver regeln
aufzustellen und begründete
entscheidungen zu treffen
deshalb werden wir es natürlich
anstreben des roboters unserer
gesellschaft auf diesem wettbewerb in
allen lebensbereichen beruht
insbesondere im politischen bereich das
heißt aber nicht dass diese opposition
sich aus dem ausland finanzieren muss
stimmen sie dem nicht zu haben sie eine
andere meinung heißt das dass die
kooperation dass die opposition frei
demonstrieren darf natürlich aber im
rahmen des gesetzes
es gibt bestimmte regeln vorsehen dass
es verschiedene formen politischen
engagement ausgibt wahlen
publikum öffentlichen
meinungsbekundungen insbesondere
demonstrationen es gibt ein gesetz und
ob dieses gesetz gut oder schlecht ist
man dieses gesetz lässt sich
demokratisch ein dann ordnung muss sein
das ist eine bekannte regeln und die
findet anwendung in allen staaten und
ist universell
ordnung muss sein manches darf kein
chaos zugelassen werden wozu ein haus zu
führen kann sehen wir am beispiel von
nordafrika
wer braucht das stichworte oppositions
tätig ich möchte sie darauf dass
politische parteien zu registrieren
musste man noch vor kurzem 50.000
mitglieder in dieser partei wir haben
radikal diese mitgliedschaft
anforderungen reduziert jetzt sind es
nur 500 menschen erforderlich um alle
politische partei zu registrieren wir
haben 37 parteien bereits in russland
mehrere dutzend parteien haben das
registrierungsverfahren beantragen wir
wollen den politischen wettbewerb weiter
entwickeln wir haben wir haben das
wahlverfahren für die mitglieder der
ober kammern des russischen parlaments
des föderationsrates geändert
die mitglieder des föderationsrates
werden auch und geheime durch religion
allgemeine abstimmungen entsprechenden
regionen gewählt
die oberklasse der bundesrepublik wird
nicht so gewählt wenn ich mich nicht
irre wird wird eine abstimmung einen
entsprechenden lassen tagen durchgeführt
in diesem sinne haben wir einen schritt
nach vorne gemacht
wahlen der gouverneure der russischen
föderation
wir haben direktwahlen von gouverneuren
wieder eingeführten der bundesrepublik
werden ministerpräsidenten im landtag
viele reeder unseren politischen kräfte
haben geglaubt werden wo das parlament
nach gemischten wahlsystem gebildet
werden soll mehrheitssystem und
direktmandate also wir sind zu diesem
system übergegangen
wir sind auf der suche nach der
politischen organisation unserer
gesellschaft die den bedürfnissen der
menschen entsprechen würde und das gilt
auch für politische parteien natürlich
wünschen wir politischen politische
konkurrenz sie fahren nach deutschland
zu einer großen wirtschaftsmesse ich
denke dass ihnen vor allem die
wirtschaftsbeziehungen am herzen liegen
haben sie sorge dass die punkte die wir
gerade besprochen haben das belasten
können
nein ich freue mich im gegenteil sehr
darüber über unser interview denn das
gibt uns die möglichkeit haben die
positionen zu klären zu erklären was in
wirklichkeit passieren und wovon wir uns
leiten lassen sie haben ja mit razzien
angefangene durchsuchungen mit
verhaftungen von welchen verhaftung
entsprechen sie dann nennen sie bitte
nur einen namen das findet die das hört
sich so an schreit nach hilfe es gibt
generalstaatsanwaltschaft der russischen
föderation die in der pflicht steht
die einhaltung der russischen gesetze zu
über alle bürger alle organisationen die
alle natürlichen und
juristischen personen müssen sich daran
halten und sie müssen die gesetze der
russischen föderation respektieren was
wünschen sie sich von ihrem besuch in
deutschland in wirtschaftlicher hinsicht
die deutschen vermutlich werden
eingeladen zu investieren was konkret
ist ja wahrlich stunden sie haben gerade
eben gesagt dass deutschland und
russland sehr bedeutende partner
füreinander sind und so ist es auch die
europäischen mitgliedsstaaten die
europäische union insgesamt ist für uns
der größte handels- und
wirtschaftspartner über 50 prozent
unseres handelns umsatzes kommen auch
die europäische union einmal mehr einmal
weniger
angesichts der schwierigen situation in
der eurozone der europäischen union
aber das ist trotzdem sehr viel
in absoluten zahlen geht es hier um 130
mit 450 milliarden us-dollar 4 sind
drittstärkste handels und
wirtschaftspartner für europa nach usa
und china und dabei ist der abstand
nicht so groß
während wir 450 milliarden
handelsvolumen mit europa die haben die
usa haben 600 wissen sie der unterschied
ist eigentlich nicht so ist in dieser
reihe partner nummer eins unter den
europäischen staaten
das handelsvolumen liegt bei uns bei 74
milliarden us dollar und trotz allen
schwierigkeiten damit es alle verstehen
können in russland und in der
bundesrepublik muss man sagen dass das
nur nicht nur zahlen sind unter diesen
zahlen stecken arbeitsplätze hinter
diesen zahlen steckt gegenseitig
ausgetauscht werden
die struktur des handelsumsatzes
entspricht nicht nur den wirtschafts
möglichkeit in deutschland sondern auch
den interessen der wichtigste
schwerpunkt liegt bei handels- und
wirtschaftsbeziehungen mit deutschland
ab
bei der industrieproduktion
dahinter stecken zehntausende
arbeitsplätze einkommen von familien in
deutschland und in russland
40 russlands den deutschen bedarf an
erdgas zu 30 prozent decken werden
wir erweitern unsere zusammengearbeitet
hoch technologischen bereich beim
flugzeugbau bei maschinen und anlagenbau
bei nanotechnologien aussichtsreichen
entwicklungen
das ist eine sehr vielfältige
interessanter und aussichtsreicher
zusammenarbeit
deutschland ist einer der größten
investoren für russland es gibt 25
milliarden us-dollar akkumulierte
investitionen in russland die deutschen
investitionen kommen sehr gut an der
russischen wirtschaft an das ist sehr
wichtig dass es sehr interessant und
dass er sehr zukunftsweisend das möchte
ich unterstreichen wir werden sechs
große pavillons bei der hannover messe
wir haben eine sehr gute lösung den duft
die industrieproduktion also dass es
immer die stärke deutschlands gewesen
und wir haben ein großes interesse an
diesen bereichen diesen pavillons werden
in der hannover 1 durchs leben messer
über 100 zur russischen großunternehmen
vertreten zu sein und ich lade sie ein
und alle unsere deutschen freunde zur
hannover industriemesse zu kommen und
natürlich unsere russischen paar videos
zu besichtigen
sie haben die zahl genannt 27 milliarden
deutscher direktinvestitionen in
russland
ich will die brücke zu zypern schlagen
bei der zypern krise jetzt haben viele
deutsche zum ersten mal bewusst
wahrgenommen wie viel russisches geld in
zypern liegt und fragen sich warum
sollen deutsche unternehmen europäische
investitionen in russland finanzieren
während viele russen ihr geld außer
landes bringen
verstehen sie denn wirklich nicht wie
absurd ihre frage ist bitte nehmen sie
mir ist nicht übel israel was hat denn
rechtlich gegen russland anleger in
einem europäischen mittelstand damit zu
tun
je mehr sie ausländischer anleger in
finanzinstitutionen in ihren ländern
anzapfen desto besser ist es für uns
denn alle verletzten alle
eingeschüchterten wir hoffen wenigstens
darauf oder die vielen werten zu uns
kommen und werden ihr geld in unsere
banken bringen
viele russische einleger seinerzeit ihre
gelder zum beispiel nach zypern
verbracht ganz offen sagen dass
russische finanzsystem als nicht sicher
angesehen haben
erinnern sie sich zum beispiel an das
jahr 1998 da kam es zu einem einbruch im
jahr 2000 das ist doch unser gemeinsames
problem
dann gab es große ängste in bezug auf
das weiterbestehen
eine neue krise kam haben wir nicht nur
unser finanzsystem stabilisiert wir
haben das gefestigte und kein
finanzinstitut ist bei uns eingestürzt
wir haben niemandem erlaubt seine
einleger zu verlassen
natürlich hatten es die menschen schwer
haben dass krisenzeiten aber wir haben
die zusammenarbeit mit bankensystems so
gestaltet dass wir es nicht nur
unterstützt haben sondern auch bestärkt
haben und bestimmte schritte eingeleitet
haben um dieses system zu recht trug
tour ihren um es auf diese weise zu
festigen und ich hoffe sehr die menschen
es auch heute verstehen werden dass zur
enteignung der einleger korwisi der
russischen einleger in zypern oder in
anderen stellen
starten ist ein vertrauensverlust
gegenüber dem bankensystem der eurozone
jetzt zur frage wer wie unterstützt
werden sollen wer ist schuld die
menschen die dort hingegangen sind die
durch die irgend ihre gelder dorthin
gebracht haben sie haben ja keine
gesetze verletzt sie haben die
zyprischen gesetze nicht verletzt die
haben die europäischen gesetze nicht
verletzt und und plötzlich hat man sie
angezeigt ihre einlagen zu 17 zu 60
prozent ist das gerecht sie haben ja
nichts verstoßen dass dieses land eine
geldwäsche anlage gewesen ist so muss
das unter beweis gestellt werden wissen
wir nicht dass es ganz klare regeln gibt
uns einen klaren regeln heißt
unschuldsvermutung nachgewiesen dass der
mensch sich etwas zuschulden kommen
lassen so ist dieser mensch unschuldig
wie kann man diese diese fragen
übersehen da kann man doch alle zu
schwindlern und betrügern erklären diese
offshore zone sie wurde ja nicht von uns
geschaffen
das ist das werk der europäischen union
oder die zyprischen regierungen haben
dies geschaffen und die europäischen
mächte haben es zugelassen ist das die
einzige offshore zone die von
europäischen mitgliedsstaaten ins leben
gerufen worden ist oder vielleicht gibt
es andere offshore diesen
großbritanniens oder irgendwelche
anderen zonen und sie glauben das ist
schlecht dann sollen sie dieser zonen
schließen
für alle probleme die in diesem land
entstanden sind
die einleger verantwortlich gemacht von
wo sie auch kommen reden russische
bürger und soßen oder wer auch immer ich
habe ja die führung der europäischen
kommission getroffen ich aber sehr gutes
persönliches verhältnis
zu ihnen aufgebaut wir streiten sie
helfen die viele fragen ist in russland
daran schuld dass es dort probleme
gekommen ist wenn man ein wiederkommen
dann unterstützen sie dadurch das ganze
bankensystem des landes und die ganze
wirtschaft des landes durch ihr
vertrauen ärgern sie sich dass zumindest
nach allem was ich war es die
europäische union sie nicht früher eine
puk hat wo doch in zypern so viele
russische unternehmen und staatsbürger
betroffen sind
wenn jetzt genießen nabarro trust nein
natürlich nicht
im gewissen sinne freue ich mich sogar
darüber denn das hat gezeigt
konsistenten und wie unzuverlässig die
einlagen bei westlichen banken sind
übrigens mit haben wir eine sehr
vorteilhafte besteuerung als bei ihnen
13 prozent sind ist bei uns die
einkommenssteuer und etwas zahlen sie in
deutschland das wäre schön
das ist schön wenn es bei uns
13 prozent wählen an unserem wahlkampf
wird wahlkampf gemacht mit
steuererhöhungen so kämpfen sie doch
bitte um die steuer eine herabsetzung
herr präsident ich will beim thema euro
bleiben
sie haben aus ihrer sicht über die
schwächen des finanzsystems in europa
gesprochen
russland hat soweit ich weiß etwa 40
prozent seiner devisenreserven in euro
angelegt also das ist ihr vitales
interesse
vertrauen sie dem euro noch also ich
möchte vorne weg stellen wir vertrauen
dem euro
er vertraue nämlich die politik der
direktor wirtschaftspolitik der
europäischen großmächte die kunst der
politik der führung der bundesrepublik
deutschland
wissen auch verschiedene meinungen
hierzu zur entwicklung der wirtschaft
zur unterstützung des
wirtschaftswachstums zur unterstützung
der währung auf den mit dem zunächst
ursache behoben werden müssen die die
krise hervorrufen und erst dann müsste
man liquiditätsspritzen verpassen aber
ich will jetzt nichts ins detail gehen
und diese polemik einmischen die uns
eigentlich nicht direkt betrifft dass es
die angelegenheit der europäischen
staats und regierungschefs aber was wir
hören und was wir sehen von dem was
unsere kollegen in den führenden
wirtschaften der eurozone machen von dem
was von der europäischen kommission
unternommen wird ich wiederhole
in vier fragen haben wir
meinungsverschiedenheiten aber bezüglich
grundlegender fragen glauben wir dass
man dort richtig handels auf dem
richtigen wege ist und gerade das stimmt
uns optimistisch es richtig gemacht
haben dass wir einen so großen teil
unserer gold und devisenreserven und
unsere sommerserie überhaupt in
europäische währung angelegt haben und
ich bin zuversichtlich sollte sich diese
situation so weiterentwickeln werden
unsere kollegen und freunde in europa
die schwierigkeiten meisten
schwierigkeiten meistern mit denen wir
heute konfrontiert werden wir haben ganz
große reserven wir haben 534 milliarden
us dollar reserven der zentralbank
hinzu kommen noch 89 milliarden
us-dollar des reservats der regierung es
gibt noch 87 milliarden das ist der
dritte nationale holst als wohlfahrts
von also das sind große gelder herr
präsident
unsere zeit ist fast um aber ich möchte
auf einen anderen krisenherd zu sprechen
kommen der den deutschen große sorgen
macht das ist syrien
jeden tag 200 menschen und entkommen
die position des westens und ihrem wohin
sicherheitsrat waren unterschiedlich das
ist ausgetauscht da gibt es
unterschiedliche positionen mich
interessiert wie sehen sie die
möglichkeit das blutvergießen dort zu
verändern was tun die russischen
behörden was tut die russische regierung
von diesen blutvergießen ein ende zu
setzen
die ziellinie ich glaube die
feindseligkeiten müssen unverzüglich
gestoppt werden und und die
waffenlieferungen müssen sofort gestoppt
man sagt uns immer wieder russland
liefere waffen an assad aber es gibt
keine verbote für waffenlieferungen an
die rentierenden lege tieren am berner
regierung billige shixin und he put nur
über die an syrien anliegenden flughäfen
ich glaube new york times darüber
geschrieben hat die opposition in
letzter zeit drei 5000 tonnen rüstungen
und munition erhalten
das muss gestoppt werden ich und ich
möchte aber ein weiteres mal
unterstreichen ich glaube das ist eine
äußerst wichtige sache es gibt doch
völkerrecht es geht doch
völkerrechtlicher normen nach deren
maßgabe
die von mir waffenlieferungen an die
regierungen die die situation in einem
anderen land auf bewaffneten wege
destabilisieren wollen
unzulässig sind diese normen liegen ja
auf dem tisch sie sind ja von niemandem
aufgehoben worden
wenn man sagt dass assad gegen sein
eigenes volk kämpft wissen sie das ist
doch der bewaffnete teil der opposition
dass dieses massaker passiert ist ja
eine plage ist eine katastrophe
den muss ein ende gesetzt werden alle
rivalisierenden parteien müssen an den
verhandlungstisch gebracht werden und
das müsste der erste schritt sein den
mann einzuleiten
diskus habe und mir bei diesen
diskussionen muss folgendes
herausgearbeitet werden was ist aus
unserer sicht wichtig ich habe bereits
öffentlich dazu geäußert das will ich
ihnen auch erzählen ich will dass ihre
zuschauer es auch wissen worin liegt an
unsere position nicht das nicht darin
dass assad heute geht für das von
unseren partnern vorgeschlagen und
morgen morgen möchte man sich damit
auseinandersetzen was weiter zu machen
ist und dass es bereits praktiziert
worden in anderen ländern
es ist unklar wohin sich mühen nicht
dass dort eine ebenso schwierige
situation wie im irak ein pferd wie im
jemen
unsere position liegt darin dass alle an
den verhandlungstisch gesetzt werden
dass alle rivalisieren teilen sich
einige wie ihre interessen eingehalten
werden und wie sie sich an der
regierungsführung beteiligen werden
werden
und wenn die internationale gemeinschaft
garantien abgegeben hat wird man an
diesem plan gemeinsam erfüllen vor
einigen monaten hat übrigens entgelt
mann darüber gesprochen und das wurde
auch vereinbart
doch unsere westlichen partner sind dann
von diesen vereinbarungen abgerückt ich
glaube man muss ganz beharrlich daran
arbeiten gegenseitig vorteilhafte
lösungen zu finden
kürzlich war der französische präsident
herr roland bei uns zu besuch der hatte
eine reihe interessanter aus meiner
sicht macht sarah ideen aber die
diplomaten müssen das noch in angriff
nehmen wir sind bereit und sie zu
unterstützen und man soll versuchen
diese idee in die tat umzusetzen
herr präsident ich möchte schluss den
bogen schlagen zu dem thema mit dem wir
eingestiegen sind demokratie offenbar
ein kontroverses thema ich will ihren
ministerpräsidenten zitieren der hat
gesagt er mit weg über die entwicklung
von demokratie in russland wird man erst
in hundert jahren urteilen dürfen
das klingt für unsere ohren nicht sehr
ehrgeizig sagt man das wenn man
demokratie in wirklichkeit gar nicht
ich glaube das lag vielleicht an der
übersetzung dürfen sie es bitte noch mal
sagen ministerpräsident mit wwf hat
sinngemäß gesagt über die entwicklung
von demokratie in russland wird man erst
in hundert jahren wirklich urteilen
dürfen
ich habe gefragt ist das nicht ein
bisschen wenig ehrgeizig sagt man das
wenn man demokratie gar nicht mehr weiß
nicht ob er das wirklich gesagt hat
man muss das im kontext sehen ich diesen
kontext sehe ich ja gar nicht dass wir
uns eindeutig für demokratie entschieden
haben und dass wir uns keine anderen
entwicklungsweg vorstellen ist
offensichtlich dass bestimmte standards
zur anwendung kommen nur schwer
angewendet werden können den anderen ist
auch eine tatsache
basierend auf den fundamentalen
demokratie prinzipien müssen wir solche
instrumente aus arbeiten die der
überwiegenden mehrheit der menschen in
unserem lande es möglich machen die
innen- und außenpolitik zu beeinflussen
das gilt für die mehrheit und dass diese
mehrheit die minderheiten respektiert
und ihre meinung berücksichtigt wenn wir
das ganze haus unserer innenpolitik alle
unsere ins staatlichen institutionen auf
dieser grundlage stellen werden so
glaube ich könnten wir über einen erfolg
der demokratie in russland sprechen aber
dass russland sich auf diesem wege
befindet dass russland diesen weg geht
ist eine offensichtliche tatsache
es reicht ja zuschauermassen der
sowjetunion gewesen ist was gerade auf
uns momentan stattfindet wie sich die
wirtschaft bei uns entwickelt wie der
politischen bereich vorankommt wie
oder wie sich alles entwickelt was die
volksvertreter anbelangt
der unterschied ist ja kolossal oder
wollen sie dass wir in zwei jahrzehnten
den weg gegangen sind den anderen
staaten
200 300 oder 400 jahren gegangen sind
natürlich muss alles schrittweise
stattfinden schritt für schritt tun aber
wir verstehen wohin wir uns bewegen und
wir werden von diesem weg nicht
abgekommen dann erlaube ich mir zum
schluss noch eine persönliche frage sie
waren acht jahre präsident sind dann ins
amt des ministerpräsidenten gegangen
jetzt läuft wieder eine sechsjährige
amtszeit gibt es an persönlichen plan
wollen sie solange präsident bleiben wie
es geht wie sie gewählt werden oder
denken sie manchmal über ein leben
danach
ich glaube wer ein jeder normale mensch
so bin ich auch ich gucke über einen
bestimmten horizont hinaus und
langlebiger politiker auch kein
europäischer politiker es gibt in europa
politiker die viel länger als ich erste
plätze in der politik innehatten und
viel länger gearbeitet haben als ich
momentan arbeite in europa in
nordamerika in kanada aber ich hoffe
sehr dass nach dem abschluss meiner
politischen tätigkeit meine staatlichen
tätigkeit ich die möglichkeiten haben
werde auch anderen fragen nachzukommen
ich mag literatur ich mag
rechtswissenschaften und ich hoffe sehr
dass ich es schaffen werde jetzt einmal
ohne konkrete verbindung mit der
politischen arbeit auch anderen
gesellschaftlichen oder sportlichen
aktivitäten nachkommen kann
herr präsident vielen dank für das
gespräch bedanke mich ich bin ein
gemisch